these are 17 conversations maybe
millions in my 20s number one I was
going back and forth between quitting my
job and starting a gym or starting my
entrepreneurial Journey another early
Mentor he sat me down and said man I've
been listening to you waffle for months
now he said at some point you're not
going to know anymore you just have to
jump he said it in a way that made me
feel like a pansy I realized I didn't
need more information I'd already done
all of the research I just needed to
decide the definition of decision comes
from the Latin decadari which basically
means to cut off or kill off question
was which future was I deciding to kill
off was it the future that I was in
currently that I didn't like anymore or
was it the future that I had the
potential to accomplish the dreams that
I had by not deciding I was actively
killing off the future that had my
dreams and then I needed to choose which
one I wanted to kill number two very
beginning of entrepreneurial journey I
didn't know how to sell anything man a
mentor just said do you want to know the
secret to sales I leaned in I was like
yes please I like had my notepad out and
said the secret to sales is making an
offer so good people feel stupid saying
no and that obviously became the
subtitle of my 100 million dollar offers
book I kept thinking that I had to learn
how to like try and manipulate going
through sales scripts and building
Rapport and sure some of those skills
are useful to have when it's so much
easier to just find things that people
really want Chick-fil-A doesn't need to
sell you on chicken sandwiches they just
have amazing chicken sandwiches and
people go buy them and that forever
changed how I created new products
created new Services was I started with
how do I get the most people to say yes
and then work backwards number three my
next mentors was a 10 billion dollar Co
he always said you got to go slow to go
fast he kept repeating it to me over and
over and over again you only unlock the
compounding which later on grows
significantly faster than the erratic
activity of small thing here small thing
here new thing here new thing here then
just doing the same thing for an
extended period of time and so what
feels slow in the micro looks fast in
the macro when you look at the
trajectory over a long period of time
but what looks really fast in the micro
is usually really slow in the macro
because people can never get that
compounding start harnessing because
they're always starting back over at
Ground Zero whenever you change
something the one cost is guaranteed is
that change will have to get paid for
and what isn't guaranteed is that it's
going to work you know you have this
fixed cost which is how you should see
it is that whenever you change something
you have to pay a price number four the
next lesson I learned was in level of
effort one of my really mentors who told
me about flyers I thought I needed to go
put a lot of Flyers out to get business
put out 300 Flyers so I called the
mentor back up and I was like hey this
didn't work and he said you know what
was your test size what do you mean by
test side and I just put out 300 total
you just laughed 300. you're not gonna
know anything with 300 he's like we test
with 5 000 and then we do 5000 a day
after that five thousand a day 150 000
Flyers a month I might have been doing
the right thing all along but I was just
doing far too little of it and at that
point I decided that whenever someone
gave me advice I wouldn't let the volume
of activity to be the reason it failed
but I just hadn't done enough of them or
I hadn't done them long enough I see so
many smaller younger entrepreneurs who
do something for Too Short too little
time not enough volume that they might
have been doing the right thing they
just didn't wait long enough or they
didn't do enough of it number five I was
at actually a mastermind and I saw a guy
get up and he seemed so disorganized and
he said yeah you know we're making three
or four hundred thousand dollars a month
it's like we've been stuck here for a
few years Layla and I were actually
together at this point we both looked at
each other and we're like if this guy
can do it we can do it it was one of
those moments that beliefs are broken
because what you find out is that they
are made of the same thing as you rather
than write off this guy's such an idiot
despite bite him being an idiot he's
still more successful than me imagine if
I used my work ethic and my intelligence
and when I shifted my perspective from
that way I was able to start using other
people's successes to fuel me rather
than to make me feel bad it switched
from wanting to cast stones at people to
being inspired by them and thinking if
they can do it so can I within six
months of seeing that conversation
happen we were already doing a million a
month number six at a different event I
went up and I spoke and I told my whole
plans if I wanted to build this national
gym chain be America's next gym the guy
who ran the Mastermind said you know
what Alex I don't think you should do
that at all I was crushed and he said I
think you have a level 10 skill set and
a level two opportunity one of those
simultaneously incredibly encouraging
things and Incredibly heartbreaking
things so it's a very like emotional
moment for me he was both encouraging me
to say that I could have been doing more
and this person from the outside put a
bar up that was significantly higher
than what I was shooting for and that
stretched my Horizon for what I was
capable of and I think getting around
people who can do that for you is one of
the most valuable things you could
possibly have in your life what he
didn't say was a level two opportunity
as he was defining it an opportunity
that has low leverage there wasn't a
very good compounding vehicle for
Capital the fact that I was successful
in what most consider a shitty
opportunity he saw as the skill sets
that would create a much bigger win
later if you are in a lower level
opportunity I wouldn't say be upset
about it I would say you're learning
with extra resistance against you you're
getting stronger now and then when you
go onto the moon where gravity is
lighter you just knock it out of the
park number seven it was a private event
it was ten people everyone was doing
eight figures or more a year and I got
invited a guy came up to me and this guy
had done 27 million dollars in a single
bag holy this guy's made more in a
day than I've been my entire life he
said fat pitches in life don't come very
often when it gets easy is when you need
to go hard otherwise there's someone
who's 10 times bigger than you who's
going to take everything you have and
not even think twice about it that was
literally fueled by that one
conversation if you're like wait how are
you doing three or four hundred thousand
a month taking over 300 I had like no
employees and I was making it all myself
you do have one of those opportunities
that comes up in your life when things
start working really well that's when a
lot of people ease off the gas that's
when they go easy when it gets easy is
when you go hard because you don't have
that many fat pitches in a lifetime you
might get two or three and you just
gotta crack the out of it when it
comes and expect that you're going to
sacrifice some short term for some long
term later number eight the same event a
different guy came up to me he said
you're scared well you're like doubling
every month with this current thing like
why do you want to start a supplement
business what if you just spent three
times as much on marketing and didn't
start us up on the business I didn't
start the supplement business I actually
delayed it for 18 months in the next
three months we tripled the ad spend and
went from 400 to 780 780 to a million
from a million to 2 million just the
next six months because of that piece of
advice and I think the underlying part
of that advice is that when something is
going well oftentimes entrepreneurs
think great I won how can I get another
win but the real win is just doing 10
times more of that thing the hardest
part is getting product Market fit it's
getting people to want to buy The Thing
Once you have that you don't need to
innovate that anymore all your
innovation has to go through how can we
do more volume number nine the next
lesson was from a guy who had a big
e-commerce brand so he was doing like 30
million a year at the time and I was
like oh my God this guy is God he gave
this huge presentation that was like two
hours long he said so pick a percentage
whatever it is 10 20 of your marketing
spend and put that towards new ideas
expect to lose it but when you're losing
it you're gaining the lesson you're
gaining the experience and what happens
is he's like you know four out of five
times my crazy ideas fail he's like but
one out of five they crush and become
the Leading Edge Innovation that pushes
us to the next level I immediately took
a number and I wrote down what my new
learning budget was going to be and it
gave me permission to spend money
without a return immediately you think
big picture he just extended my time
Horizon for a return and so rather than
saying I have to make my money back
immediately within 30 days of me
spending this I said if I extend my
Horizon over my lifetime if I spend this
money I will learn and be better and I
will learn faster than somebody who
doesn't I just gave myself a budget to
say it is acceptable to lose this and
then I committed to that and that was a
huge pivot point for how we were able to
scale and try new things and I looked
forward to spending on my learning
budget every month and it just gave me
permission to be creative knowing that
it would be okay to fail number 10. the
next one I got from a pastor between
Layla and I he gave us a single piece of
marriage advice that we have taken today
we have used countless times in our
lives both in our marriage personally
and professionally in the business he
said if you don't agree don't move
forward it was such a simple piece of
advice because we have always made our
decisions together and if we don't agree
we slow down a lot of times we impose
this false sense of urgency on ourselves
when there's almost nothing that is
urgent like unless you're going to die
which is the only real urgency then a
lot of times taking an extra second to
think okay is there something we're
missing is there a frame that we're not
seeing if we don't agree first question
we always ask is what information are
you using oftentimes one of us will have
data that the other person doesn't
because we have the same values and same
Mission we do ultimately come to the
same decisions that has saved me so many
mistakes number 11. I went to a big half
a billion dollar Mastermind so there was
like 10 of us there and the total sales
of everyone in the room is about half a
billion dollars but I was still among
the smaller ones I think we were doing
30 or 40 million dollars a year at the
time and plenty of guys there we're at
100 you know 200 Etc what do they have
are they smarter are they working hard
are they sacrificing more like they had
a bigger total addressable Market they
had a bigger Tam they were going after
just a much wider audience so you start
small so the riches are in the niches
but at a certain point you do need to
open up the aperture so like Facebook
started with you know college right that
the niche and then slowly spin it over
time I had to open up my eyes and say
you know what maybe I can go broader in
some way number 12. this was one of the
first billionaires that I ever met I'd
been stuck at 30 to 40 million for like
three years there was a lot of learning
that I was trying to do in this period
to break through that wall I was telling
him all these things that I was doing to
try and grow my business and he just
laughed he said it's not about you it's
about everybody else and what he meant
by that wasn't like me versus customers
or anything like that he was like all
you've been telling me is what you're
going to do you need to have a stable of
stallions you need to give people a
slice of the pie and let them get rich
too and up to that point I had hoarded
everything I was like you know what got
me from a 100 million dollar Top Line to
500 million dollar Top Line doing less
and getting really smart people to help
me out and giving them a Big Slice it's
about Talent it's about people you have
to get other people who can make
decisions on your behalf and you feel
not only that they were as good as your
decisions but even better because the
beginning your jack of all trades master
of none but you need to have Mastery in
every Department of the business in
order for it to scale and you can either
see that as I have to learn everything
or the faster way which is I can go buy
it through through other people who've
already given 10 years if I can get 10
people who've all spent 20 years in
their respective departments I basically
have 200 years of experience and if
every person in the organization has
learned everything from you then it's
only one brain and one lifetime that is
the limit of the organization that thing
is what got us past the 30 to 40 million
that was a huge breakthrough for me
number 13. the next conversation I had
was really the one that pushed me over
the edge I have a famous friend I was at
his house and we were sitting at the
kitchen table and I said don't you get
tired of all these weirdos like
messaging you stuff and like sending you
threats and like three people a week
stopping by your house like trying to
climb your fence like it's not like not
fun he said if that's the price I have
to pay to make the impact I want to have
then I would pay it every day of the
week for whatever reason it just like
stabbed me in the heart and it made me
feel like if I want to spread a message
if I want to help more people that
there's a cost to it having now been a
little bit the other side and having
more recognition and whatnot is that
Fame has pros and cons there are cons
but I believe that there are more Pros
than cons are there things that are
inconvenient now absolutely you get
stopped every time you go to dinner like
you get distracted it's harder to be
like private public if you have a bad
day you can't do it because someone says
hi and it's the one time they're going
to see you there are things that are
gone but the pros outweigh the cons you
get amazing people who will come and
want to work with you you get amazing
teammates who otherwise would never know
you exist who also have the same Mission
have the same values and it creates
significantly more alignment and real
world value in terms of economic value
how much money you make by having people
inbound coming towards you I used to
talk about people make guns I was
like you know do cold Outreach and run
ads like don't talk to me but now having
been on the other side of it I can tell
you that it was mistake number 14 big
influencer I said hey you're way further
ahead of me like how do I just shortcut
this thing and so he said hey start
making content on every platform so I
did that and then I came back six months
later and I said hey look we went from
zero to you know 200 000 people in our
audience in six months and you noted the
progress but I was like what's your
blueprint what's the what's the model
give me the flow chart he said dude we
don't have a flow chart anybody's trying
to tell you that is trying to sell you a
system you just need to do so much more
volume than you currently are he said
just pull up your Instagram and pull up
my Instagram so I pulled it up pulled it
up he had posted five times I had posted
once he's like pull up your LinkedIn
pull up my LinkedIn get posted 7 in
times I'd posted once platform by
platform you get pulling one up and he
was embarrassing me with the amount of
content he was putting out compared to
me so in the next six months I put 10
times the content out and we grew 10
times faster the interesting lesson I
learned from this is that there are
principles that are ubiquitous the more
work you do the more you get so the
boring work applies to everything in
business whether it's relationships
whether it's cold calling whether it's
making content the more you do the more
you get number 15. the next one is about
investing I was actually a pretty big
pansy when it came to investing and this
was the Breakthrough I had I had all
this money and people were like I've got
this real estate deal I've got this
crypto thing when you have lots of money
deal flow is not a problem what I didn't
have was a set of rules or parameters
and you have to make those otherwise you
get too much decision fatigue you waste
too much time doing diligence on deals
reading having multiple phone calls
having lawyers come in and then deciding
not to do it this one conversation I had
changed my life he was telling somebody
who had a lot of real estate experience
if you were to put a circle on this
table what percentage of your brain
knows real estate he was like I guess 85
okay what percentage of your brain knows
stocks and stuff he's like 10 or 15 he's
like that is your new capital allocation
parameter 85 of your net worth should be
in real estate 15 should be in stocks
and it was so simple for me I know
business and so what do I invest in now
only businesses only risky if you don't
know what you're doing I can write a
five or ten million dollar check and be
fine if I know if it's a business
because I understand I know what
pitfalls are going to come up like I get
it sticking with that just forever made
my life simpler because now when deals
come to us I'm like that's just not in
my wheel and I can just immediately say
that so the amount of time and effort
and lawyer calls and conversations that
that saved me has paid so many dividends
and now are investing doing
significantly better because it's what I
know and I feel comfortable with it and
I can move way faster number 16.
leverage behind a product Naval has said
you only sell because you know how to
Market you only Market because you know
how to build a product an exceptional
product is a quadratic relationship with
your audience good marketing or good
sales is a linear relationship if you
make an exceptional product something
that's so unbelievable that people
cannot help themselves but tell other
people about it one person buys the
product and they sell two two tell four
four Tel eight how do I do that you work
on it and you keep work on it and you
don't make new products until the first
one's right and if you're like that
might take years that's why good
takes time 100 million offers that book
continues to sell more copies every
month with zero advertising dollars
actually less work in the long run to
build a better thing than it is to build
a shitty thing and then have to spend
the rest of your time marketing and
selling it you want to have leverage in
every aspect of your business and the
product is the strongest one number 17.
the last one I learned from Uncle Warren
the power of brand brand was always this
amorphous thing that I thought was
complete BS I was like you can't
quantify blah blah blah but the thing
and quantify brand and that is what I
learned from Uncle Warren he said the
amount that you can charge above the
commoditized version of your product the
Delta there is the power of brand if you
have a t-shirt that can sell for twenty
dollars normally and can sell for a
hundred dollars with your brand on it
all of that pricing power goes to bottom
line which is why Warren Buffett invests
in Brands it's one of the strongest ways
to retain pricing power the brand itself
becomes a huge compounding vehicle
because the audience and the awareness
around the brand compounds